[Music]
this is a court of law the standards of
evidence are completely different court
accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth i think it's about time to accept
the existence of the devil
i'm here to tell our story there's not
one day in my life
that goes by that i never think about it
it's always there it scars you
i met arnie when i was working down in
bridgeport
when arnie and i rented a home my
brother david
he started getting physically attacked
where arnie comes into play arnie
witnessed what they
assumed was a demonic possession with
david
david was suffering so bad and we're all
right there with him
arnie couldn't take it anymore because
he was trying to help my brother
clean it alone
at his wit's end he called out to nadine
and invited him into his own
and when he had challenged the beast
it gradually started to manifest and
come to him
february 16 1981 my boss
started to really become inebriated
your girl's gonna think i'm a drunk
arnie said let's get out of here
he started walking down the stairs and i
heard a guttural yell
out of arnie and then i turned around
looked at my boss he's on the ground
and i seen blood all on his shirt
i think i hurt someone
the newspaper came and i told him what
happened i
said he was possessed
i want the truth to be told that these
things are
real something terrible happened here
you cannot take this lightly
good versus evil it's real
you